it's Michelle of loud muffin beauty
science here again with more skin care
related chemistry notary today we're
going to be discussing a misconception
that's quite common in skincare
communities
it's about fatty acids and oils this
might sound really abstract and
theoretical but it's fundamental to
understanding why some claims about oils
aren't as valid as they sound for
example you might see lauric acid is 15
times better at killing acne bacteria
than benzoyl peroxide coconut oil is 50
percent lauric acid so coconut oil is
going to be fantastic at killing acne
bacteria or a lake as it disrupts your
skin barrier since argan oil contains
about 50% oleic acid it will disrupt
your skin but chemistry and biology say
otherwise let's chat about fatty acids
and triglycerides
an acid in organic chemistry is a group
that contains a carbon double bonded to
an oxygen atom and an O H group this
hydrogen can ionize which is what makes
it an acid fatty acids have this acid
rope connected to a long nonpolar
hydrogen and carbon chain this chain
makes the chemical field greasy and
fatty hence the name fatty acid there
are a range of fatty acids there are
saturated fatty acids which contain no
double bonds like lauric myristic
stearic and permitting acids there are
mono saturated fatty acids that have one
double bond like a lake in sappy annek
acid and polyunsaturated fatty acids
that have multiple double bonds like
linoleic and linoleic acid some
unsaturated fatty acids are called omega
fatty acids the Omega refers to where
the double bonds are
a triglyceride also known as a tri a
solicitor looks like this it has one
glycerin molecule connected to three
fatty acids via water called ester
linkages triglycerides are the main
components of the common fats and oils
that you'll nerve the vast majority of
plant oils like olive oil sunflower oil
coconut oil but also fats like beef fat
and lard
if you zoom into the ester linkages in a
triglyceride you'll notice that the COOH
acid groups aren't there anymore they're
technically aren't any fatty acids in
the triglyceride at all that's because
the acids have undergone a chemical
reaction to make the triglyceride so
they're no longer acids so what happens
is this o H on the fatty acid comes off
and a hydrogen on the glycerine also
comes off and they connect like that so
you can see the acid no long has that H+
that can come off and so it's no longer
an acid it's a little bit like how
sodium metal and green chlorine gas
undergo a chemical reaction to give
sodium chloride which is white and salt
and delicious not green or metallic or
gas like at all
but chemical reactions can be reversed
under the right conditions that's why
you'll see lots of nutritional advice
saying that fish oil is a good source of
essential omega-3 fatty acids even
though the actual fish oil contains only
triglycerides
lipase enzymes from your saliva stomach
and pancreas break up the triglycerides
and turn them back into free fatty acids
this breakdown reaction is called
hydrolysis so makers also talk about
oils in terms of the percentages of
fatty acids contained in them because
the main step in soap making involves
performing a chemical reaction with lye
to break up the covalent bonds in the
triglycerides to free the fatty acids
but plant oils contain very little free
fatty acids in general you have less
than 1% free fatty acids in the oil that
haven't been either transformed into the
triglyceride or have broken off the
triglyceride too many free fatty acids
actually makes the oil rancid which is
when it smells and tastes off for
example coke on
oil can't be sold if it contains more
than not 0.5% free fatty acids virgin
coconut oil has an average of not 0.1
percent free fatty acid cold-pressed
unrefined rose hip oil has about 2% free
fatty acids so when we put oils on our
faces were applying very little free
fatty acids so the question is do we
have life phases on the surface of our
skin that can break up these
triglycerides if yes then using oils is
the same as using the free fatty acids
but if not then it's like going to a
restaurant and ordering a steak and
being given the steak while it's still
attached to the cow it turns out that
the answer is quite complicated
I've actually been wondering about this
and reading about it on and off for
about three years and I've been talking
to my nerd friends slash cosmetic
chemists Stephen about it a few times
and I finally sat down and read through
hundreds of references before coming to
a conclusion that I'm somewhat confident
with I've included the most relevant
references here but if you're really
interested in the science and the
chemistry behind it all I'd encourage
you to do a proper literature review
yourself
there are enzymes called lipase ins in
your skin that can break up
triglycerides some of these are made by
humans but a ton of these are made by
microorganisms living in your skin
most of these live under the surface of
your skin in your pores humans produce
an oil called sebum in the sebaceous
glands under the skin when it's at the
bottom of the pore near the sebaceous
gland it contains a high amount of
triglycerides
and almost no free fatty acids but by
the time it gets to the skin's surface
around 1/4 of this has broken up to give
15% free fatty acids scientists in the
70s did some experiments and found that
P acnes the acne bacteria is the main
microbe that produces these lipase
enzymes that break down the
triglycerides but other species can
produce lipase enzymes too for example
Mullis a sea of fungus staff and cornea
bacterium the vast majority of these
organisms and their lipase enzymes sit
inside the pores there's also a lipase
that your body makes in the living
epidermis of your skin that then gets
released into the stratum corneum with
the rest of the lipids so thoroughly
paises and theoretically they can break
down the triglycerides to give free
fatty acids but how much and how fast
they aren't that many studies that we
can look at to see how much and how fast
triglycerides get broken down to give
the free fatty acids when they're
applied to the surface of your skin so
here's what I've managed to find in the
1950s there was a radioactivity study
where radioactive tri Palmerton
which is the triglyceride of par michig
acid was applied to that someone's back
for two and a half hours then wiped off
and analyzed 6% of the Grady after try
Parmesan was broken up versus
approximately 30% of the triglycerides
in regular sebum so why was this figure
so low the scientists who did this
experiment suggested that it was likely
that the oil in the surface couldn't get
into the pore whether lipase enzymes
were and even if it did it would
probably get pushed out by the new sebum
that was coming out of the sebaceous
glands 6% into anahatha sounds like
quite a lot especially when you think
about how long all stays on your skin
overnight
but only a really tiny amount of the try
Parmenter was used in this experiment it
was not a 5 milligrams which converts to
nought point 5 6 microliters one drop of
water is about 50 microliters so this is
one hundredth of a drop which was
applied over 300 square centimeters
which is about this much skin if you use
more oil then it's even less likely that
will get into the pool and so you'll
have an even lower percentage another
study used mixtures of the lake acid as
the free fatty acid and glycerol try
ollie 8 which is 3 alayich acid
molecules bound up bonded to glycerine a
lake acid as a free fatty acid is known
to be a barrier disrupter they made a
bunch of mixtures that were zero percent
free fatty acid and 100 percent
triglyceride 25 percent free fatty acid
50 percent free fatty acid and 100
percent free fatty acid they applied one
drop of each mixture to the forearms of
12 people covered it with gauze
gave them plastic wrap so they could
cover it while they were showering they
looked at the sites the next day first
they measured the trans epidermal water
loss or te WL which is the leakiness of
the skin to water leaving they found
that the sites with 100% triglyceride
had no change from the untreated areas
of skin the trans epidermal water loss
for the rest of the sites was directly
proportional to the amount of free fatty
acid oleic acid the scientists also
measured how easily chemicals could
penetrate the skin going in using
fluorescent dye the depth of the
penetration of the dye was proportional
to the amount of a lake acid as well so
these results suggest that only very
negligible tiny amounts of triglyceride
were actually broken up into the free
oleic acid but at least anything that
was broken down to give alayich acid was
immediately turned into something else
that didn't disrupt the skin barrier or
perhaps they just didn't end up in the
same place applying free oleic acid and
applying a lake Asif bound up in
triglycerides definitely did not have
the same effect at least within the time
frame of the experiment which was 24
hours there was a third study which was
a longer-term study in this study they
made a cream which contained linoleic
acid rich oils which were sunflower and
borage seed oil
there was also a plain placebo cream and
both of these cranes were applied to dry
skin in winter they were applied twice
daily for four weeks on the inside forum
of eleven different people each person
applied the active cream to one arm and
the placebo plain cream to the other arm
then afterwards the scientists analyzed
the lipids in the stratum corneum they
looked at the ceramides free fatty acids
and cholesterol content after four weeks
they found that there was actually less
free fatty acids in the treated area
compared to the plain cream but they
found that the levels of ceramide 1
linoleic which are ceramides with
linoleic acid attached were nearly
doubled on the treated pot compared to
the plain cream while the same type of
ceramide but with a leg acid attached
was much lower it's also worth noting
that in sebum in the free fatty acid
portion there's actually less
unsaturated assets like linoleic acid
and oleic acid than in the original
triglycerides so what this suggests is
that some free fatty acids linoleic acid
an alayich acid a selectively removed
after triglycerides are hydrolyzed or
broken down and used to make other
substances like ceramides
[Music]
so what does this mean from these
studies we can see that triglycerides
applied on skin aren't broken down to
give you free fatty acids on your skin
this is important because in
pharmacology the dose is very important
for example if you take one ibuprofen
painkiller tablet it's less effective
than taking two taking one ibuprofen
pain tablet might get rid of your
headache but taking tiny portions of one
tablet over three days won't be
noticeable it's even more complicated
because breaking down the triglycerides
depends on microorganisms and different
people have different microorganisms on
their skin for example men have more
microbes on their skin than women and
other factors like climate and genetics
will make a big difference to different
parts of your face and body also have
different microorganisms one study found
that Sieben triglycerides were
hydrolyzed more quickly at the nose than
on the Feraud taking antibiotics will
change your skin's microbes obviously
but so will other things like using
different cleansers creams and
antibacterial products so in conclusion
we shouldn't rely on oils for the
properties of their free fatty acids
unless they've been shown to be
effective at very low concentrations
although having them in an oil and
having them in a solution of alcohol
which is how they usually test the
activity of these free fatty acids will
have very different effects on how well
they penetrate your skin but this
doesn't mean that all oils are useless
they can still be very beneficial for
example oils are often excellent
moisturizers they can be occlusive and
slow down how quickly water leaves your
skin and make it dehydrated plus they
work as emollients that soften your skin
there are also very good basis for all
soluble ingredients and sometimes they
naturally have beneficial ingredients in
them for example rosehip oil contains a
few forms of vitamin A mostly beta
carotene but there's also a tiny amount
of retinoic acid or tretinoin in there
as well they can also potentially be
good sources of fatty acids for making
ceramides in your skin as shown in the
study on sunflower and bird seed oils so
in summary oils contain fatty acids
bound up in triglycerides not free fatty
acids applying skin care oils won't give
you the same effect
as applying the free fatty acids that's
all from me today if you like my videos
I'd love it if you could subscribe to my
channel and like my videos I also have a
blog where I have lots and lots of
beauty science you can also follow me on
Facebook and Instagram where I post lots
and lots of skincare tips based on
science see you next time
[Music]